à peine sorti du commissariat il a fait
arrêter le fourgon près d'une voiture
suspecte regardez cette jeune fille
pourquoi faire pour y mettre le joint
mais voici que le capitaine arrête une
voiture cette femme va se retrouver
mêlée à la ferme elle va assister à la
fouille comme un huissier avec ce témoin
pris au hasard la police est vite toute
contestation sous le siège avant
les policiers viennent de retrouver ce
sac le capitaine a eu du flair il y a
des amphétamines
le sac appartient à cette femme
pour elle les sanctions sont immédiates
on va mettre tout le monde au courant
vos employeurs votre famille vous allez
être fiché maintenant et on vous enlève
le permis immédiatement parce que les
toxicomanes n'ont pas le droit de
conduire conséquence en cascade la
Russie ne plaisante pas avec la drogue
[Musique]
ce sont mes premières images de
Saint-Pétersbourg lumière dorée et
cathédrale au fil de l'eau
la Venise du Nord m'en met plein les
yeux
je me balade dans un décor riche et
coloré une ville immense posée sur la
mer Baltique
c'était le rêve d'un tsar Pierre le
Grand
il en avait fait sa capitale comme une
porte ouverte sur l'Europe
mais entre temps elle fut aussi la ville
de Lénine Léningrad
ne reste du communisme que les bibelots
qui se vendent sur les marchés
les nouvelles icônes sont capitalistes
et trônes à tous les carrefours
je n'imaginais pas le pays aussi riche
il y a aussi les laisser pour compte les
babouchkas avec leur petites retraites
et tous les soldats oubliés
d'Afghanistan ou de tchétchin
Saint-Pétersbourg a aussi une sale
réputation je garde en tête des bribes
de journal télévisés à la chute du mur
on l'appelait la Capitale du Crime 5000
morts en 10 ans dans les réglements de
comptes de la mafia
moi aussi j'ai fait la une des journaux
pour des crimes que je n'avais pas
commis c'était outro c'était il y a 10
ans aujourd'hui je garde une passion
pour les affaires de police et de
justice
[Musique]
pendant mon séjour je vais plonger dans
la criminalité je partirai en patrouille
avec la police de nuit
je verrai les ravages de l'alcool et la
faune des commissariats
je remonterai les pistes celles des
violences d'extrême droite avec
l'interview choc d'un leader néonazi
c'est aussi
du avec la confession d'un mafieux au 5
téléphones
je serai témoin de la violence ordinaire
des bagarres de trottoir au crash de
voiture
je ferai aussi l'expérience de la
violence gratuite montée en spectacle
avec le Free Fight à mi-chemin de la
boxe et du combat de gladiateurs pour
m'ouvrir les portes la jeune garde des
journalistes russes Yuri d'achat et
Natacha spécialiste des faits divers il
m'entraîneront dans le monde de la nuit
techno champagne et cocaïne avec parfois
une descente des forces spéciales
ce voyage dans les coulisses de la
société me donnera les clés pour la
comprendre comme un passeport pour le
crime
[Musique]
Saint-Pétersbourg ne dort jamais 4
millions d'habitants
comme dans toutes les mégapoles du monde
la nuit est plus violente que le jour
commissariat numéro 7 secteur central il
est 20h
c'est la première fois qu'une télévision
étrangère est autorisée à suivre la
police de Saint-Pétersbourg mon tournage
commence à l'armurerie
le numéro 10 s'il te plaît
on nous donne des balles de quoi remplir
deux chargeurs
sont strictement
frères de la Kalash
a des modables ils sont sûrs et simple à
manier
les patrouilleurs de services se mettent
au garde à vous
un pas en avant marche demi-tour
présentez votre carte
vérification des plaques de police
en Russie la police prend parfois des
allures militaires
ordre vous est donné de prendre votre
service en respectant la correction la
plus absolue vis-à-vis des citoyens
prêts à vos postes marche
qu'on se le dise on ne badine pas avec
la déontologie et on fait respecter
l'ordre sans brutalité
[Musique]
c'est un samedi soir pic d'activité pour
la police la patrouille ne va pas chômer
c'est à dire dégagez votre véhicule
dégagez et police
première appel une bagarre à la sortie
d'un bar
j'ai vu personne je sais rien moi
on t'a cassé le nez ou quoi les dents
quatre dents en moins et le nez cassé il
y a peut-être aussi un traumatisme
crânien
applique le coton
au plus vite voici
à quelques mètres les videurs du bar
observent la scène d'un drôle d'air ils
sont-ils pour quelque chose les
ambulanciers font monter la victime mais
le capitaine n'en a pas terminé
tu peux essayer de me parler maintenant
à l'abri de l'ambulance le jeune homme
finit par désigner ses agresseurs
les trois videurs du bar mais ils ont
disparu
[Musique]
le capitaine banov par les chercher à
l'intérieur
[Musique]
peine perdue ils ont pris la fuite
un avis de recherche est lancé
la victime part à l'hôpital
nouvel appel une embrouille dans un
restaurant
c'est à quelques rues seulement
ici les noctambules n'ont pas de
problème de fin de mois
la patrouille pousse la porte d'un
endroit plutôt branché
vous êtes de la sécurité
je suis de la sécurité c'est juste qu'il
y a une table un peu agité là-bas il y a
même eu des coups de poing ok allons
voir au fond ces deux clients refusent
de payer l'addition on leur facture une
bouteille de vodka qu'ils affirment ne
jamais avoir commandé le problème c'est
qu'ils l'ont bu
ils sont sortis manu militari direction
la cellule de dégrisement
on l'emmène au poste dans cet état il
joue la comédie tu vois bien
le premier à filer droit l'autre va
résister
[Musique]
ça n'a pas été facile mais regardez bien
la porte du fourgon est restée ouverte
l'homme a réussi à sauter du fourgon
mais au jeu du gendarme et du voleur
c'est la bouteille de vodka qui va faire
la différence
[Musique]
avantage aux gendarmes qui eux n'ont pas
bu
la vache
ment
fléau des fléaux en Russie
et pour la patrouille les interventions
se suivent et se ressemblent
querelle de sans-abri dans les couloirs
du métro
à l'arrivée de la police plus de force
pour se battre
pour les hommes l'espérance de vie est
tombée à 58 ans les
ivrognes se font ramasser par la
patrouille
panier à salade puis garde à vue
surprise au commissariat l'ambiance
s'est assez calme et même sobre pourtant
ces jeunes sont là à cause de l'alcool
on attend d'être tranquillement des
copains et on avait de l'alcool avec
nous dans sac les flics nous
embarquaient juste pour faire grossir
les statistiques
pourquoi ces coups de filet
est-ce que la loi a changé
interdiction de boire une seule goutte
d'alcool dans la rue un comble en Russie
mais aussi une injustice les plus
modestes n'ont pas d'autres endroits
pour boire
la jeunesse dorée elle s'enivre à l'abri
et à 7 euros le verre
7 heures du mat la patrouille de nuit
est rentrée se coucher
les hommes du capitaine banov m'ont fait
plutôt bonne impression
quelques heures de sommeil plus tard
j'ai rendez-vous à l'autre bout de la
ville petite leçon de débrouille avec
Marina ma traductrice faudrait qu'on
trouve une station de taxi peut-être on
n'a pas besoin à trouver en taxi on peut
faire juste en geste comme ça et
n'importe quelle voiture s'arrête pour
nous amener où on veut n'importe qui
peut te prendre
[Applaudissements]
finalement les gens sont assez
sympathiques je trouve parce que on
s'aide comme ça écoute oui mais ça peut
être dangereux quand même tu as déjà eu
des cas de problème
et puis des vols aussi d'accord ça vous
arrive souvent de prendre des passagers
comme ça
je vois les jolies filles comme vous
taxi improvisé ça arrondit les fins de
mois et ça met de bonne humeur de
ramener les jolies filles
merci beaucoup en tout cas
j'ai rendez-vous à la rédaction de fond
en cas
pour les faits divers c'est la référence
à Saint-Pétersbourg font en cas à l'oeil
sur tout
n'est pas un journal classique mais un
site internet
bonjour oui c'est Yves gaming le patron
un ancien flic
dirige 20 journalistes et c'est choisi
un emblème qui donne le ton
vol des infos à part ça on se ressemble
c'est quelques mètres carrés sont le
cœur même de notre site c'est ici que la
formation se cuisine
il y a peu de collaborateurs encore
moins de mètres carrés mais d'après ce
qu'on raconte nos infos sont les
meilleurs
conférence de rédaction l'ambiance est
tendue une lettre anonyme reçue ce matin
même dénonce un meurtre gratuit
un meurtre qui aurait été commis par des
policiers
[Musique]
deux agents du FSB en état d'ivresse ont
pris à partie monsieur catch attourian
qui rentrait chez lui
ils l'ont violemment battu et quand il
était à terre il lui en tiré plusieurs
balles dans la tête avec leur pistolet
de service un assassin
incroyable les meurtriers seraient des
officiers d'élite membre de l'ex KGB
rebaptisé FSB je vais d'abord vérifier
dans le quartier si c'est vraiment
arrivé et puis on pourra partir de là
pour savoir s'ils sont du FSB ou pas
Tatiana est chargé du dossier sous ses
airs juvénile c'est une journaliste
confirmée elle appelle ses sources au
sein de la police
l'histoire est plausible
la police russe est connue pour ses
bavures voici par exemple comment peut
se terminer un carambolage
[Musique]
les femmes ne sont pas mieux traitées
ces images amateurs prouvent le
tabassage la police elle plaidera
l'outrage
[Musique]
sa réponse sous couvert d'anonymat ses
contacts l'ont briefé sur la ferme
que les tireurs étaient bien du FSB ils
étaient bourrés et ils ont dû commencer
à brancher la victime la victime a
répondu et alors ils l'ont tabassé
il est mort mais il y a un témoin
ok je vais dire à Julia de contacter le
tribunal militaire
je décide de me rendre sur place sur les
lieux du crime
[Musique]
au carrefour une photo de la victime un
petit hôtel a été improvisé à l'endroit
où il a été abattu
[Musique]
en un certain nombre je pensais que
c'était un accident de la route et je
découvre que c'est tout autre chose je
suis choquée c'est même gens qui sont
censés nous protéger tue des innocents
c'était notre voisin on le voyait tous
les jours dans la cour à réparer des
voitures il était mécano c'était un bon
père de famille
quand j'ai appris sa mort j'étais sous
le choc comme les meurtriers sont du FSB
les témoins risquent de recevoir des
menaces par téléphone ils vont subir des
pressions ou même être attendu en bas de
chez eux
cette voisine a raison de se méfier
nous apprenons que les deux assassins
présumés habitent le quartier et
viennent d'être relâchés
je frappe à la porte de la veuve Natacha
Tourian
elle se taire chez elle et vit avec les
rideaux fermés même en plein jour
Natacha et viadi son d'origine
arménienne ils se sont rencontrés et
mariés à Saint-Pétersbourg c'était il y
a 12 ans
j'ai deux enfants je ne sais pas je
n'imagine même pas comment je vais vivre
sans lui je ne sais pas
c'était la personne la plus importante
dans ma vie qui mettait la plus proche
et la plus chère il était mon compagnon
mon ami il était tout
natacha est perdu
elle a mis ses deux enfants à l'abri
d'éventuelles représailles
le plus jeune
je considère que de tels individus n'ont
pas leur place au sein du FSB
comment voulez-vous qu'on leur fasse
confiance maintenant comment
je ne sais pas
en tout cas je ferai tout ce qui est
dans mon pouvoir
je ne laisserai pas passer ça
[Musique]
une femme seule commence un long combat
pour la justice
demain matin à rassemblement est prévu à
la mémoire de son mari
[Musique]
rendez-vous est pris
10 heures
Natacha mène le petit groupe la famille
quelques amis
pour ce dernier geste ils ne sont qu'une
poignée des Arméniens pour la plupart
[Musique]
leur silence me surprend
j'imagine les manifestations de colère
qui auraient eu lieu en France
cette communauté meurtrie est-elle
résignée ou seulement recueillie
aucun voisin n'a voulu ou oser se
joindre à la cérémonie
pourtant tout le quartier est au courant
un homme veut me parler
c'est un ami de la victime le dernier à
l'avoir vu vivant
nous étions chez moi à parler autour
d'un thé il est parti après deux heures
du matin oui j'ai entendu les coups de
feu bien sûr mais je n'aurais jamais
imaginé que c'était lui
la Russie d'aujourd'hui est loin d'être
sans danger dans la rue oui il peut
arriver n'importe quoi pour rien et il
vaut mieux éviter de se précipiter vers
un agent en uniforme pour demander de
l'aide c'est aussi dangereux
la justice russe sera-t-elle identifiée
et punir les coupables
si la police s'attaque aux citoyens le
sentiment d'insécurité est sans limite
les habitants de Saint-Pétersbourg ont
pourtant bien besoin d'être protégés il
y a ici 10 fois plus d'homicides qu'en
France braquage prostitution drogue des
faits divers chocs pour un JT qui n'a
pas froid aux yeux celui de TSB 10
minutes par jour sur l'insécurité
ordinaire à Saint-Pétersbourg
et la reine du frisson c'est elle Elena
vichnifskaïa elle présente depuis ce
petit studio je dois me faufiler entre
les câbles
vous êtes présentatrice de l'émission
depuis combien de temps
ça fait 10 ans oui
ce journal de faits divers bats des
records d'audience malgré ses petits
moyens
voici d'achat l'une des six journalistes
de l'équipe
un sujet que nous avons tourné le
week-end dernier samedi
nous avons suivi dans une boîte de nuit
une descente de la brigade des
stupéfiants
on travaille très régulièrement avec la
police
il y avait les forces spéciales qui
contrôlaient les clients du club pour
savoir s'il y avait de la drogue sur
c'est un classique du métier pour
alimenter l'antenne et fournir 10
minutes de crimes chaque jour le plus
simple est de travailler avec la police
moins 3 degrés
de chaud d'achat m'a donné rendez-vous
le lendemain au commissariat numéro 64
[Musique]
reportage du jour l'arrestation de deux
dealers
[Musique]
tu vas faire quoi là alors
on va faire des interviews avec tout le
monde sur l'affaire qui concerne ces
deux jeunes gens qui ont été interpellés
nous avons pu trouver sur l'un d'eux
cette plaque de couleur marron
ressemblant à la substance narcotique
appelée haschich
et que disent les prévenus à ce propos
ne lui appartiennent pas
dans ce sac plastique le kilo de
haschich saisi par la police
[Musique]
on a rien fait enquête le démontrera
quand on nous a arrêté on n'avait rien
sur nous
[Musique]
innocent ou pas il passeront dans le
journal ce soir entre la télé et la
police c'est gagnant-gagnant
c'est votre quotidien aussi de
travailler en collaboration avec les
journalistes
nous faisons aussi des appels à témoin
à la télévision il nous recueillons
ensuite le témoignage de ceux qui les
ont reconnus
ça nous permet d'étoffer le dossier
d'instruction
le tournage continue
le cameraman est comme chez lui
une seconde les gars vous allez reculer
un peu vous allez me refaire votre
entrée puis vous fermerez la grille et
vous ferez quelques pas droit devant
vous
les policiers jouent le jeu ils sont
tous fans de l'émission
et la collaboration marche dans les deux
sens
on va se mettre d'accord sur deux trois
questions de toute façon que ce soit
vous ou non il y a pas une grande
différence donc je vous propose comme
première question c'est il de quoi il
est accusé
et puis ensuite de quoi le suspecte-t-on
c'est ce qu'on appelle une belle
complicité la télévision est même
autorisée à faire ce qui serait
impensable en France poser des questions
au suspects c'est entre l'interview et
l'interrogatoire
vous avez le droit de ne pas répondre
aux questions qui vous seront posées
j'ai compris
vous dites que quelqu'un vous a demandé
de faire ça mais vous connaissez ces
gens ce qui vous ont demandé ce service
je connaissais une des personnes c'est
pourquoi j'ai joué le jeu j'ai fait ce
qu'il me demandait vous voulez dire que
c'est quelqu'un de proche de vous non
juste une connaissance cela doit faire
six mois que je le connais 7 tout au
plus je ne sais pas
avec ce genre de mise en scène on voit
mal comment la télévision pourrait un
jour critiquer la police d'achat assume
cela ne me choque pas du tout je trouve
qu'il est important de montrer les
criminels voilà et je pense que dans une
certaine mesure les médias aident à
élucider un grand nombre de crimes
[Musique]
le soir venu je regarde la séquence à
l'hôtel
le visage du dealer présumé n'est pas
flouté il n'est pas jugé mais au
tribunal de l'audimat c'est comme s'il
était déjà coupable
[Musique]
du temps de l'Union soviétique la
télévision diffusait les procès des
ennemis du communisme aujourd'hui il en
reste peut-être quelque chose
70 ans de dictature pour le visiteur de
passage ce n'est que du folklore mais
dans les esprits et dans les lois l'URSS
n'est pas morte exemple avec une
institution qui a survécu la police de
quartier
[Musique]
lieutenant Alexandre vinocorov 27 ans
il est en charge d'une partie du
centre-ville 500 appartements et des
habitants qu'il connaît par leur prénom
c'est la police
[Musique]
Ivan evanovic 87 ans
Alexandre s'intéresse aux vieux fusil de
chasse divan
comme ça chez les personnes qui ont des
armes
sont commis avec des armes non
enregistrées
nous faisons un recensement et des
vérifications
peut-être que le coup a été tiré avec
cette arme là
oui mais peut-être pas avec ce fusil de
chasse
[Applaudissements]
au royaume de la kalachnikov les armes
de guerre circulent sous le manteau pour
moins de 100$
la police vient de vous contrôler comme
ça ça ne vous dérange pas
s'il y a suffisamment d'armes qui
circulent dans notre pays comme dans le
vôtre d'ailleurs
c'est bien comme ça
allez au revoir
[Musique]
pour Alexandre toujours le même accueil
sympathique et coopératif
cette vieille dame est l'une de ses
meilleures informations
elle a grandi sous l'air soviétique à
l'époque la dénonciation était un devoir
citoyen
[Musique]
les communistes faisaient la chasse aux
bourgeois les plus beaux appartements
étaient confisqués
on y logeait les plus modestes une
famille dans chaque pièce
Alexandre m'emmène dans l'un de ses
appartements communautaires
bonjour c'est la police de quartier
à l'intérieur un bric-à-brac et des
odeurs de cuisine plusieurs familles
sont assises et cette locataire est très
en colère
je suis encore en train de nettoyer les
toilettes en rentrant du travail et je
les ai retrouvés dégueulasse
qui d'autre chez toi ma femme
et tu te plains de ne pas avoir d'argent
discuté
sa femme sous les couvertures ne s'est
même pas aperçu de notre présence
tu as entendu le chien ils sont à la
maison c'est sûr et qu'est-ce qu'ils
font ils se saoule
[ __ ]
il n'est pas interdit de se saouler chez
soi Alexandre ne peut rien faire
là c'est la cuisine chaque occupant à sa
place attitré
à manger des placards de rangement
chaque chambre à son coin
à chacun ses provisions et pour tous
cette baignoire la cuisine fait aussi
salle d'eau
c'est dans cette pièce que la
promiscuité est la plus grande avec
parfois des envies de meurtre
Alexandre me raconte que cet homme a
voulu poignarder ses deux voisines
il était ivre il leur reprochait de ne
pas ranger la cuisine
ce soir les couteaux resteront sagement
rangés grâce peut-être au travail de
fourmi d'Alexandre
je suis également persuadé que ce
travail permet de diminuer le nombre
d'infractions et de délits
de quartier l'un des plus essentiels et
des plus anciens il a plus de 80 ans
[Musique]
là où nous allons maintenant c'est très
étroites
oui comme ça
[Musique]
il y aura peut-être des gens à
l'intérieur je dis bien peut-être
c'est mauvais signe parce qu'il devrait
y avoir un verrou fait attention
c'est des excréments
monsieur bonsoir
je suis le policier de quartier que
faites-vous ici
j'adore là de combien vous avez des
papiers
quand est-ce que tu t'es présenté un
poste de police pour la dernière fois il
y a deux semaines
en Russie les sans-abris sont fichés
impossible de passer à travers les
mailles du filet policier encore un
héritage de l'époque soviétique
[Musique]
comme ça dans les cages
et malheureusement le travail que je
viens de faire sera bientôt à refaire
ils vont libérer les lieux pendant un
jour ou deux et après on a beau mettre
un verrou il l'arrache pas quand même
la police de quartier c'est aussi se
montrer intraitable
dehors les températures sont négatives
[Musique]
[Rires]
en Russie c'est comme si la révolution
n'avait jamais eu lieu les riches sont
très riches et les pauvres sont très
seuls
[Musique]
entre l'opulence et la misère on dirait
que l'État ne fait pas grand chose
[Musique]
je rentre à l'hôtel en taxi avec
Vladimir un ténor du volant
[Musique]
taxi karaoké il fallait la venter
Vladimir l'a fait
[Musique]
Saint Christophe patron des
automobilistes faites que Vladimir n'est
jamais d'accident en regardant son écran
[Musique]
un accident je vais en voir un le
lendemain matin l'équipe de la
télévision TSB est déjà sur les lieux
[Applaudissements]
lui a eu beaucoup de chance c'est le
conducteur de la voiture accidentée il
est encore sous le choc
ça va
pour l'instant le conducteur n'est pas
vraiment en mesure de nous expliquer ce
qui s'est passé
mais on dirait dans la partie arrière du
camion il avait peut-être déjà perdu
connaissance au moment de l'impact les
dégâts sont impressionnants mais pour
TSB c'est la routine
j'ai vu bien pire par exemple quand il
ne reste plus rien d'une voiture
là c'est encore à moindre mal
la preuve par l'image avec les caméras
de la police
toujours plus de circulation avec la
neige
la vitesse et l'alcool
[Musique]
et pas de quartier pour les piétons
[Applaudissements]
en Russie impossible de déplacer une
voiture même et gratignée avant
l'arrivée de la police une question
d'assurance du coup à chaque accident
c'est l'embouteillage assuré pour
fluidifier le trafic Vitali le caméraman
a bien une petite idée
les femmes au volant c'est plutôt
dangereux dans la majorité des accidents
de la route c'est une femme qui est
impliquée
un bras Matthieu l'homme russe
sur la route la police veille il y a les
chauffards et puis tous ceux qui ont
quelque chose à se reprocher
comment les repérer dans le flot des
voitures avec ses tailles électroniques
il reconnaît les plaques
d'immatriculation en temps réel et les
compare avec le fichier du banditisme ou
de la violence routière
[Applaudissements]
regardez bien
le capitaine est en train de nous vanter
cette technologie le conducteur impliqué
dans un accident avec des victimes
la Lada est partie sur les chapeaux de
roue
cette voiture est recherchée
[Musique]
au bout de la course poursuite pas de
mafieux en cavale mais une simple
conductrice tout étonné d'être arrêté
vous savez que votre véhicule est
recherché vous l'ignoriez alors je viens
de vous faire une bonne surprise
le véhicule en question est recherché
pour un délit de fuite la conductrice
n'est pas au courant bon évidemment on
va prendre sa déposition et faire un
procès-verbal
l'ordinateur s'est-il trompé ou bien
est-ce la bonne voiture mais pas le bon
conducteur cela promet peut-être une
explication orageuse de retour à la
maison
[Musique]
je retrouve le capitaine banov pour une
deuxième nuit de patrouille
à peine sortie du commissariat il a fait
arrêter le fourgon près d'une voiture
suspecte
tonton elle voulait faire un trou
regarde elle avait déjà commencé un trou
dans une bouteille pour la patrouille
c'est comme un flagrant délit restez ici
s'il vous plaît pourquoi vous étiez en
train de faire ça juste comme ça pour
m'amuser
oui juste comme ça
pourquoi faire pour y mettre le joint
on dévisse le bouchon et on aspire tout
le temps nous arrêter de sortir du
fourgon on s'était fait repérer par ces
jeunes qui ont pu en profiter pour jeter
ce qu'ils avaient
mais voici que le capitaine arrête une
voiture
bonjour c'est le capitaine bonne offre
de la section principale
je vous prie de m'excuser c'est juste à
faire de quelques minutes vous arrêtez
s'il vous plaît
cette femme va se retrouver mêlée à la
ferme
je dois filer à l'aéroport c'est
possible de faire ça rapidement
en fait le capitaine vient de recruter
une auxiliaire elle va assister à la
fouille comme un huissier avec ce témoin
pris au hasard la police évite toute
contestation
veuillez sortir de la voiture maintenant
va vous mettre dans le bon état d'esprit
vous n'avez rien sur vous vous êtes bien
sûr
sous le siège avant
les policiers viennent de retrouver ce
sac
ouverture sous le regard du témoin
[Musique]
le capitaine a eu du flair il y a des
amphétamines
le sac appartient à cette femme
pour elle les sanctions sont immédiates
on va mettre tout le monde au courant
vos employeurs votre famille vous allez
être fiché maintenant et on vous enlève
le permis immédiatement parce que les
toxicomanes n'ont pas le droit de
conduire mais je suis pas toxico moi oui
oui tout le monde dit ça vous savez
conséquence en cascade la Russie ne
plaisante pas avec la drogue
direction le commissariat pour un
interrogatoire
[Musique]
l'automobiliste témoin doit suivre elle
aussi sa soirée est fichue
il est deux heures du matin
dans les cellules les garder à vue
dorment des gens
la toxicomane présumée reconnaît les
faits mais elle a une explication c'est
parce qu'elle est maire de famille que
tout cela est arrivé
j'en ai pris pour me faire une opinion
si jamais un jour mes enfants ils goûte
ou que quelqu'un leur en propose je
serai ce que ça fait
c'est de la curiosité voilà tout
l'automobiliste prise comme témoin prend
son mal en patience
il est bientôt 4 heures du matin
pour que la loi soit respectée il faut
que chacun mette du sien de toute façon
c'est la règle les gens savent qu'ils
peuvent faire appel à la police alors
quand la police fait appel à eux c'est
normal que le citoyen répondent présent
sinon il n'y a pas d'ordre
bel exemple de civisme et en même temps
qu'elle a vu comme si sans témoins la
police allait forcément manipuler la
procédure
la mère de famille signe sa déposition
elle va finir sa nuit en cellule
[Musique]
à 7h avancé il existe un lieu qui
palpite comme en plein jour
l'Arena la discothèque la plus glamour
de Saint-Pétersbourg
y a-t-il ici des substances interdites
cocaïne en fait amine ou héroïne
[Musique]
en tout cas la drogue est devenue la
première cause de mortalité chez les
jeunes russes
les autorités lui ont déclaré la guerre
[Musique]
et elles le font savoir
inauguration ce matin du nouveau siège
des forces spéciales c'est l'élite de la
police
discours du nouveau super flic de la
ville le général souko dollarski parmi
ses priorités la lutte contre le trafic
de drogue
[Musique]
le lendemain je pars sur le terrain avec
les forces spéciales
le patron de l'opération me prend avec
lui
interdiction de montrer son visage
l'objectif une boîte de nuit à la
périphérie de Saint-Pétersbourg
nous sommes rapprochés
si jamais il y a une transaction nous
pourrons agir immédiatement et obtenir
le flagrant délires
un policier est déjà à l'intérieur en
civil
le patron attend son feu vert pour
intervenir
une heure plus tard un SMS
il semblerait que le dealer ne soit pas
là et qu'on est aucune raison d'attendre
plus longtemps
le dealer a-t-il flairé le piège
les hommes en noir débarquent en force
[Musique]
ambiance glauque
les derniers fêtards ne sont pas plus
impressionnés que ça
j'ai ma conscience pour moi
le patron de l'opération fait tout
retourner
et dans la salle de billard
ça ce sont les amphétamines
toi tu continues
des sachets ils en trouveront d'autres
derrière la platine du DJ
amphétamine
et même planqué derrière ce panneau
une seringue
c'est suffisant pour faire fermer la
discothèque
c'est pas comment le film américain ou
les dealers chez nous les deals se font
en général dans les appartements ou en
boîte
le quadrillage policier y est peut-être
pour quelque chose
sur la piste de danse tout le monde a
repris ses esprits c'est la gueule de
bois
test de dilatation des pupilles bonjour
mademoiselle vous pouvez me regarder
dans les yeux s'il vous plaît
merci c'est bon vous pouvez rentrer chez
vous la sortie par là
ses yeux réagissent normalement à la
lumière
bon on embarque tout au poste et on va
voir ce qu'on a réussi à trouver très
bien OK
au final nous avons quelques personnes
qui ont consommé de la drogue nous
allons continuer les interroger pour
savoir qui les a fournis quand et
comment votre mission principale est de
remonter aux fournisseurs
en attendant les policiers explorent les
lieux et font une découverte à l'étage
un jacuzzi une table de massage et des
chambres la discothèque est un bordel
les prostituées se sont envolés
l'endroit a pourtant l'air d'un simple
bâtiment commercial
impossible de deviner la main de la
mafia
la mafia c'est aussi les voitures volées
une trentaine par jour à
Saint-Pétersbourg
en Russie les petits salaires tournent
autour de 200 euros par mois
[Applaudissements]
une voiture de luxe c'est la fortune sur
4 roues j'essaye d'en savoir plus sur ce
trafic ce matin j'ai reçu un sms un
trafiquant accepte de parler j'attends
depuis plus d'une heure
le voici
au volant du plus coûteux des quatre
quatre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans le vol des voitures
en fait quand une voiture est volée
pour qu'il change le numéro
d'immatriculation
les phases des nouveaux papiers
c'est un très bon business c'est très
rentable
je pense qu'il vient en quatrième ou en
cinquième position après le trafic d'ARM
et les stupéfiants
tu survis pas dans ce business parce
qu'on peut très bien arnaquer avec le
balancer si tu fais pas ce qu'il faut tu
tombes à la première voiture
[Musique]
3 4 5 téléphones impressionnants
il faut absolument avoir plusieurs
numéros qui correspondent à des gens
différents comme ça on est paré
et est-ce que les voitures se sont
uniquement des voitures qui sont volées
en Russie ou est-ce que vous en avez
aussi qui sont volés à l'étranger
je ne fais pas ça qu'en Russie
c'est vraiment beaucoup moins risqué
[Musique]
ne peuvent pas se permettre de rouler
avec des voitures volées ce serait le
prétexte idéal pour que la police
m'arrête
ce carrosse éveille les soupçons du
gardien
notre gorge profonde sans le danger et
abrège la conversation
la mafia russe a exporté son
savoir-faire
elle contrôle le trafic de voiture volée
dans toute l'Europe
[Musique]
et c'est la spécialité de Yuri un jeune
journaliste d'investigation son cheval
de bataille même
l'objectif c'est de prouver que ces
choses là ne passent pas inaperçues à la
fois pour nos lecteurs et pour ceux qui
trafiquent
Yuri nous conduit à la fourrière
derrière ses grilles des voitures volées
qui attendent leur propriétaire
Yuri a rendez-vous avec un de ses
contacts un homme clé qui enquête pour
le compte des assurances
le numéro c'est la carte d'identité de
la voiture il est faux comme cette
plaque la voiture a été volée et
l'identité maquillée à Saint-Pétersbourg
c'est grâce aux informations du boîtier
électronique que j'ai finalement
retrouvé le numéro d'origine et son
propriétaire
Yuri prend des photos pour illustrer son
futur article
c'est dangereux
bien sûr que j'ai peur mais sinon à part
moi qui va le faire
sans surprise il y a la grosse berline
allemande et 4x4 de luxe
prenons des tractopelles en Russie on
vole tout ce qui roule il suffit d'être
bien outillé
ça c'est l'outil préféré des voleurs je
l'ai retrouvé dans la voiture avec ça
vous ouvrez toutes les serrures de la
même marque regardez ici c'est écrit
Mazda
je vais vous montrer
vous introduisez vous faites tourner et
voilà pas besoin de casser le carreau
avec ce genre de Passe-Partout
mais les voleurs ont un outil encore
plus efficace un qui rien ne résiste
quelqu'un qui veut voler une voiture a
toujours dans sa poche en fonction de la
voiture une Niasse allant de mille à
10000 dollars si la police l'attrape en
flagrant délit il sort l'argent et peut
s'en aller et parfois même au volant de
la voiture qu'il vient de voler
quelle corruption arriver à acheter ce
qui viennent de vous arrêter j'ai du mal
à le croire
[Musique]
Yuri pourtant va me convaincre direction
la police routière
et là c'est le garage des patrouilles
pour n'importe quel flics
il y a même des gens qui sont prêts à
payer pour ça
tu peux toujours te démerder pour faire
passer pour sous un mec parfaitement à
jeunes
c'est très rentable
la preuve sur ce parking voici les
voitures personnelles des policiers ce
n'est pas avec leur salaire qu'ils ont
pu se les offrir
acheter une telle voiture légalement
c'est quasiment mission impossible pour
un policier son salaire est entre 500 et
600 euros
alors qu'une voiture pareil couteau bas
mot 28000 euros c'est uniquement avec la
corruption et les polvins qu'il peut se
permettre un tel luxe regardez sur
celle-ci la plaque est même gravée
ministère de l'Intérieur
une imprudence avec cette plaque le
propriétaire a trahi son appartenance à
la police comment pourra-t-il justifier
son achat
Yuri essaye de le rencontrer peine
perdue
[Musique]
à Saint-Pétersbourg la police ne connaît
pas la crise elle est à tous les coins
de rue
tous les Russes le savent mieux vaut
l'éviter un exemple l'alcool au volant
le taux légal n'est pas 0,5 comme en
France mais 0 0 en théorie en pratique
on peut toujours négocier
sur ces images amateurs l'automobiliste
propose un pot de vin transaction
discrète dans la voiture de police le
policier ne prend pas les billets en
main mais les acceptent pour une
centaine d'euros il va rendre le permis
de la corruption est partagé avec les
chefs ici un policier en donne la moitié
à son supérieur
il y a deux ans un policier a brisé la
loi du silence le commandant Alexis
dimowski
quelques semaines plus tard il sera
radié de la police
depuis mon arrivée à Saint-Pétersbourg
je n'ai pas encore été arrêté mon
chauffeur de taxi vient de franchir une
ligne blanche
[Musique]
nous voulons quelques images
5 minutes de négociation
et le voilà de retour combien a-t-il
donné
en principe tu donnes ce que tu peux et
si tu donnes trop peu il te laisse pas
partir
1000 roubles 25 euros
pas facile d'admettre la corruption
surtout pour celui qui est corrompu
mais je vais recueillir un témoignage
exceptionnel
un gradé qui accepte de dénoncer ce
qu'il appelle le système
les généraux de la police s'offrent des
voitures à leur fils et sachent des
chats allant des centaines de milliers
de dollars et nous
entretenons les véhicules de service à
nos propres frais
l'essence pour les voitures de
patrouille et de notre poche
les stylos le papier pour les
procès-verbaux sont de notre poche aussi
l'uniforme c'est à nos frais
99% des effectifs d'une façon ou d'une
autre sont corrompues le système
lui-même les yeux obligent
le système pour qu'il change il faudra
que les policiers disent non
combien sont-ils comme cet homme a subir
en silence
cela fait 9 jours que zial dit l'arménia
est mort sous les balles de la police
aujourd'hui ses proches sont aussi
c'est une tradition orthodoxe au 9e jour
l'âme du défunt quitte le corps et monte
au ciel
Natacha la veuve sert son fils il fait
très froid autour du disparu
pour se réchauffer les uns les autres la
vodka circule
on mange sur le pouce
chagrin
et colère aussi
le Facebook devrait être le premier à
dénoncer cette affaire le premier à
condamner cette brebis galeuse
une famille honnête se retrouve
complètement livré à elle-même obligé de
se défendre par ses propres moyens c'est
le plus terrible dans tout ça c'est
au-delà du révoltant je n'ai même pas de
mots pour ça
nous avons bien des lois et des
structures qui nous protègent mais nous
devons les pousser à le faire c'est nous
qui devons mettre la machine en branle
alerter les médias passer par Internet
la loi ne bouge pas elle ne fait rien on
doit la faire bouger
cette femme souffre et elle doit en plus
se défendre toute seule se défendre elle
et ses enfants voilà comment ça se passe
chez nous
je me promets de repasser voir Natacha
avant mon départ
triste tableau
cette veuve brisée s'en remet plus à
l'église qu'elle est à
[Musique]
face à l'arbitraire face à la corruption
les victimes sont bien seules en Russie
au dehors la société est brutale
dans la pénombre des églises il y a des
paroles rassurantes et des musiques
sacrées
[Musique]
la prière comme une bulle hors du temps
comme un instant de répit
[Musique]
au dehors il y a quand même quelques
individus qui se lèvent contre l'État
contre les abus de pouvoir
[Musique]
leur nom de code voie la guerre
s'attaquer au symbole rien de plus
efficace pour ces rebelles
renverser une voiture de patrouille
embrasser les femmes en uniforme
ou narguer les pentes de la police en 24
secondes chrono
graffiti géant sur le plus grand pont
levant de la ville et voici un phallus
de 65 mètres de hauteur érigé juste sous
les fenêtres du FSB
une blague de potage qui ne fait pas
rire les autorités
voici les deux leaders devant
Natalia surnom la chèvre et Oleg surnom
le voleur c'est un couple d'artistes il
ne se sépare jamais de leur dernier nez
arrêtez relâcher poursuivi à nouveau
collègue et Natalia passent à la
clandestinité
ni téléphone ni adresse mais je finis
par obtenir un email
rendez-vous et prix
19h30 devant le Musée de la Marine
je suis avec Marina ma traductrice
personne
et puis Natalia arrive en vélo
elle vérifie notre identité
son compagnon Oleg nous observait depuis
tout à l'heure son enfant sur le dos
nous partons sur les quais de l'année va
[Musique]
je vous propose de lescendre quelques
marches histoire de ne pas attirer
l'attention
pas de problème il fait moins 5 degrés
j'ai sur mon ordinateur les images de
leurs exploits alors là cette action que
vous avez fait c'était pour protester
pourquoi
ce que nous essayons de faire avec ces
opérations c'est contester la corruption
qui étouffe la société comme les
tofraine celle de prison
la corruption empêche les gens de vivre
c'est pour ça qu'il faut la remettre en
question et de préférence de manière
forte et expressive
c'est ce que nous faisons nous les
artistes
et à lutter contre cette corruption
ce que nous aimerions par-dessus tout
c'est que les gens cessent d'avoir peur
nous essayons de montrer qu'il n'y a
rien de terrible à proclamer ses
convictions
aujourd'hui votre vie est compliquée est
difficile est-ce que vous regrettez vos
actions par rapport à ça
et nous sommes prêt à répondre du
moindre de nos actes et si c'était à
refaire nous le referions sans hésiter
fédérale de la police à travers tout le
pays donc et je suis en plus sous le
coup d'un mandat de recherche
international
mais en fait pour l'instant nous le
faisons que nous échauffer tout ce que
vous avez pu filmer c'est un
échauffement des gamines rides
adolescents mais bientôt nous serons
grands et là nous passerons aux choses
sérieuses
faut-il entendre une menace
ces agitateurs d'extrême gauche
veulent-ils passer à des actions plus
violentes
pour l'instant le danger vient plutôt de
l'autre bord
4 novembre aujourd'hui l'extrême droite
vous les défiler dans le centre de
Saint-Pétersbourg le pouvoir a dit non
ce sera un meeting en banlieue et
souhaite surveillance
voir la Russie voir la Russie
dans la foule crâne rasé et visage
cagoulé
mais aussi les plus jeunes et les plus
âgés nostalgique de la grandeur
soviétique ce 4 novembre l'extrême
droite commémore une très vieille
bataille il y a 400 ans les Russes
chassaient les envahisseurs polonais
aujourd'hui c'est une autre invasion qui
fait peur
pourquoi viens-tu ici ils viennent
prendre nos emplois et ils viennent nous
tuer et en plus ils veulent l'argent des
programmes du gouvernement vous
comprenez ça il les étrangers bien sûr
mais il y a plusieurs catégories
apparemment
moi je pense que le vrai problème c'est
le pouvoir qu'on donne aux juifs ils en
profitent pour faire venir sur notre
terre des hordes de cul noir d'Asie et
du Caucase
noir que leurs arrières petits-enfants
chiront dans leur froc rien qu'à
imaginer ce que leur grand-père auront
subi
de la haine à l'état brut
on aurait pu sans doute avec ses
drapeaux
la croix gammée n'est pas loin
et le passage à l'acte non plus
regardez bien
ce jeune manifestant est armé
[Musique]
un tirant l'air comme une sommation
parfois il n'y a pas d'avertissement
Moscou décembre 2010
5000 crânes rasées déferle dans les rues
pour venger l'un des leurs
[Applaudissements]
chasse à l'homme et d'élite faciès
heureusement la police s'interpose 30
blessés dont 6 graves le pire est évité
[Musique]
qui sont ces militants néo-nazis
voici leur chef
Dimitri bobbroff
un nom qui sent le soufre l'ancien chef
de schools 88 un groupe muscul de
sinistre mémoire
[Musique]
au début des années 2000 il semait la
terreur à Saint-Pétersbourg
bataille rangée passage à tabac
agression gratuite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
violence allait jusqu'à l'irréparable
au moins un meurtre raciste par mois
Yves guény s'en souvient le patron du
site font en cas à enquêter sur ses
mouvances néonazis
au premier rang Schulz 88 le mouvement
de Bob Rohff
voilà ce qu'ils édite
il s'agit d'un journal illégal
mais c'est un journal quand même et là
vous avez un deuxième une vraie œuvre
d'art signé Schulz 88
vous y trouvez tout et n'importe quoi
j'ai eu entre les mains leur programme
politique je peux vous dire que le son
verset pendant la Révolution d'Octobre
ou la Révolution française c'est rien en
comparaison
non vrai comme ça ce sont des vrais
dangers publics des monstres capables de
crever des yeux d'assassiner un des
leurs devoir du sang
et là il s'agit du corps découvert par
la police d'un de leurs combattants
ils avaient décrété que c'était un
traître et un traître ça s'exécute
des dangers publics à qui le pouvoir de
Poutine va casser les reins
les meurtriers prennent perpétuité
les mouvements sont dissous les meneurs
sont arrêtés comme beau prof qui fera
trois ans de prison
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il est libre et ne renie
rien
il accepte de me rencontrer
[Musique]
vous êtes le fondateur du groupe 88
où en est votre groupe aujourd'hui
notre organisation
et la plupart purge encore leurs peines
aujourd'hui
mais beaucoup de nos anciens membres
continuent à lutte avec des méthodes
totalement différentes
que pensez-vous de la jeune génération
est-ce qu'elle partage vos idées
à la marche russe vous avez dû remarquer
que la plupart des participants étaient
déjà
qui viennent de tous les milieux sociaux
nous avons le peuple et l'opinion
publique derrière nous en fait le
discours public au cours de ces
dernières années est devenu complètement
nationaliste
on n'aurait jamais pu l'imaginer à
l'époque aujourd'hui ceux qui
participent à nos événements sont une
toute petite partie seulement de ceux
qui nous soutiennent
curieux paradoxe
auraient perdu la bataille de la rue
mais gagner celle de l'opinion
je vais m'en rendre compte le lendemain
balade au marché
le marché à praxinevor
les visages sont méfiants
azéri géorgien arménien ici tout le
monde parle russe mais avec l'accent
c'est le cas de firdase Fairouz et
Forcade trois immigrés 3 frères ils sont
nés à 4500 km d'ici au Tadjikistan
il m'emmène dans ce parc ou firdase à
cru mourir
c'est ici le chemin était très étroit
avec de la neige de chaque côté je
marchais seul quand ils sont venus à ma
rencontre ils étaient quatre ils m'ont
donné un coup d'épaule puis on
commençait à m'insulter ensuite un dégât
assorti un couteau de sa poche et a
voulu se jeter sur moi
le temps que mes frères arrivent j'étais
déjà par terre ici
on m'avait donné 8 coups de couteau puis
mes frères se sont battus avec les
Russes qui ont fini par s'enfuir
parce que je ne suis
pas ça se voit non
c'était des nationalistes ils m'ont
attaqué pour ça il me criait que la
Russie n'était pas pour nous mais pour
les Russes qu'ils allaient la nettoyer
des mecs comme moi voilà ce qu'il disait
il me traitait de cul noir
[Musique]
vous vous rendez compte il me donnait
des vrais coups de couteau
pas des coups de poing non des coups de
couteau et plusieurs à la suite j'ai des
cicatrices il voulait tout simplement me
tuer
d'ailleurs ils l'ont admis pendant
l'instruction ils ont dit oui on voulait
sa peau
[Musique]
oui bien sûr je peux vous les montrer
j'en ai encore une ici et plusieurs dans
le dos
qui sont les agresseurs de firdase
néo-nazi ou jeune sans histoire
ils se réunissent ici tous les samedis
très tôt le matin il y a une salle de
sport là-bas vous voyez
c'est leur salle de sport ils y viennent
tous les samedis pour s'entraîner c'est
là-bas quelque part derrière ces
bâtiments
voici la salle de sport le club du
Diable Rouge
beaucoup de jeunes et un entraîneur
aussi musclé que méfiant
il nous refuse l'entrée
[Musique]
cet homme c'est romane zensoff champion
d'esport illégal en Europe le free fight
[Musique]
1,85 pour 104 kg pour la boxe ce serait
un beau gabarit maisensoft ne fait pas
de box
[Musique]
au Free Fight tous les coups sont permis
point pied ou genou
[Musique]
l'arbitre laisse couler le sang
un tournoi est programmé pour le
surlendemain
direction les quartiers nord
immeuble récents et pelouse impeccable
ici les appartements coûtent cher
le Free Fight séduit les classes
moyennes
à l'extérieur du gymnase une quinzaine
de policiers
à l'intérieur une centaine de
combattants ils sont à l'échauffement
comme n'importe quel sportif
car oui pas de doute c'est bien un sport
ce serait même bon pour la santé
n'est-ce pas Michael
nous faisons partie des gens qui se
battent pour un mode de vie sain
contre les drogues l'alcool les
cigarettes
en gros pour le triomphe du sport
un esprit sain dans un corps sain
il y a quand même ce tatouage 88 un
vieux code 8 c'est pour la 8e lettre de
l'alphabet le H
8 8
= h c'est-à-dire
non non ça rien à voir ce sont les 88
commandements en fait les commandements
de la nature
c'est pas beau de mentir comme ça
[Musique]
ça sert à rien de vous agglutiner pour
les présentations vous vous mettez en
rang moi je passe le premier et vous me
suivez
[Musique]
comme ça c'est sûr que l'avenir du pays
est assuré chacun de nous est prêt à se
battre pour son pays à défendre nos
proches et notre famille dans les
moments difficiles ici on élève pas des
sportifs on élève des guerriers
ici l'essentiel n'est pas de participer
mais de vaincre les tatouages annoncent
la couleur
les free Fighters se battent pour de
drôles de drapeaux de drôles de slogan
celui-là savoir combattre posséder
celui-ci vive le règne de la race
blanche si le Free Fight est un sport
alors c'est un sport fasciste
nous avons parmi nous plusieurs vétérans
des membres des forces les plus
performantes et les plus prestigieuses
de notre pays les spexnases on les
applaudit
encore plus fort c'est un officier
commando qui patronne la compétition
bonjour à tous
un immense merci à vous tous
car c'est un vrai bonheur pour l'âme et
pour les yeux de voir tous ces hommes
capables de défendre leur patrie
de défendre leur famille
de défendre leur propre personne et leur
prochain
merci
[Applaudissements]
scène surréaliste le vétéran distribue
des médailles aux poussins
l'endoctrinement commence au plus jeune
âge
[Applaudissements]
début des hostilités les victoires se
font par abandon ou par chaos
Michael se prépare
et c'est parti pour 3 minutes de combat
Mickaël l'emporte avec cet étranglement
[Applaudissements]
je suis super content j'ai gagné et je
suis très content je suis toujours prêt
pour le combat moi je suis un combattant
de rue la différence avec les sportifs
c'est que nous les combattants de rue on
est toujours prêts si on me réveille au
milieu de la nuit ou qu'on vient de
surprendre sous ma douche au milieu de
mon petit déjeuner pour me dire on se
fait un combat je répondrai toujours
d'accord on y va
je comprends maintenant ce que voulait
dire Bob Rohff
plus besoin d'être néo-nazis pour avoir
des idées extrêmes
la société russe tout entière s'est
radicalisée
et Yves Guenni le journaliste a peur de
ce qui pourrait suivre
l'état d'esprit général en Russie et le
suivant il y en a assez de tous ces
immigrés viront-les
pas quelqu'un doit prendre le relais
bon quand les choses vont jusqu'au
meurtre les gens reculent tu es c'est
mal donner une correction pourquoi pas
mais tu es non
avec eux ce qu'il faut craindre c'est
qu'ils aillent plus loin qu'il se
mettent à faire des bombes
espérons qu'il guérisse trompe
[Musique]
c'est l'heure du départ
avant de rentrer à Paris je vais faire
mes adieux à Natacha
cette femme en deuil qui m'a tellement
touché
elle m'attend chez elle avec son avocat
et ce qu'elle a à me dire est incroyable
est-ce que vous avez été entendu par la
police Natalia
[Musique]
moindre idée de ce qui est dans le
dossier en me cache tout vraiment je ne
comprends pas
ce que lui octroie pourtant notre
Constitution
en tant que participe elle a le droit de
savoir quelle mesure a été prise à
l'encontre de l'inculpé on refuse de
nous donner une réponse claire à ce
sujet c'est vous dire et en
tant que
je vais réfléchir à ma réponse car ça
peut me coûter ma carrière d'avocat rien
ni personne ne me garantit une
protection ou cas où je rassure des
agréments ou quoi que ce soit
d'approchant cela pourrait commencer par
ce n'est qu'une supposition mais disons
par des écoutes téléphoniques mais si ça
ne suffisait pas ça pourrait continuer
avec des mesures de plus en plus corsées
est-ce que vous avez espoir que justice
sera faite
bien sûr
on a envie de croire qu'au moins une
fois en Russie justice sera faite
mais j'en doute
Natacha fera-t-elle condamner les
meurtriers de son mari
en tout cas elle ne passera pas les bras
le simple combat d'une victime à côté
d'autres combats d'autres victimes pour
qu'un jour enfin la Russie devienne un
État de droit
pour qu'un jour enfin la Russie n'est
plus tout à fait les mêmes faits divers
[Musique]